هل دخل المجنون خط الحرب
لينضم إلى حليفته موسكو ضد الغرب؟
وصل القطار،
إنه قطار خاص ومصفح،
نزل منه وصعد إلى سيارته سريعا،
ياااا إلهي من كان ذاك يا ترى؟
ولماذا كل هذه الجلبة؟
وكل هذا التعتيم على هذه الشخصية؟
سيارة فخمة وصلت إلى مكان ما،
لا أحد يعرف أين هذا المكان،
الزعيم الروسي في الانتظار!
نعم فلاديمير بوتين الذي جعل الزعماء
والقادة ينتظرون لوقت طويل ليقابلهم،
هاهو اليوم يقف منتظرا وبكل سرور،
توقفت السيارة ونزل الضيف المنتظر،
هل عرفتموه؟ إنه الرئيس المجنون! ماذا؟
نعم إنه زعيم كوريا الشمالية، كيم جونغ أون؟
ما الذي تفعله في روسيا أيها المجنون؟
لكن مهلا متى كان ذلك يا ترى؟
كان ذلك قبل أربع سنوات من اجتياح بوتين
لأوكرانيا،
بوتين يصافح جميع الشخصيات المرافقة للمجنون
وبحرارة على غير عادته،
والمجنون يهمس في أذن بوتين، وكله شغف،
(هيا لنضرب أمريكا ماذا ننتظر؟)،
يريد محو واشنطن من الخارطة،
عن أي مجنون نتحدث؟،
وعن أي دولة يتحدث هو؟
إنه يتحدث عن أقوى دولة على وجه الكرة الأرضية،
إذا ما العمل ياسادة، فقد عاد المجنون
بعد أن كبح جماحه في تلك المرة
وخرج هذه المرة بعد أن غزت موسكو كييف،
وقد دخل اليوم خط الحرب مع روسيا
ضد أوكرانيا والهدف الأساسي لهم هو
الغرب وأمريكا،،،
فهل دقت ساعة الصفر للحرب العالمية الثالثة؟
بينما ازدادت حدة المعارك وتكثفت الضربات
برا وجوا، المدن الأوكرانية تسقط واحدة
تلو الأخرى أمام الدب الروسي،
الناتو وأمريكا والغرب عموما
يستمر بالتنديد مع تلويحهم بعقوبة تلو أخرى
لكن هل تثني العقوبات الدب أن يصل لهدفه،
ثلاث دول ستدخل مع حليفها الروسي
بانتظار التوقيت المناسب،
(الصين وإيران) لم يدخلن بعد
لكن كوريا الشمالية أعلنت دخولها وانضمامها
للحليف الروسي،
وحتى إن أعلن الثلاثة دخولهم معا،
فلن يكون دخول الدولتين كدخول بيونغ يانغ الحرب،
فالزعيم المجنون لا يمزح أبدا
ولا ينظر خلفه مطلقا، إنه كالقطار
يدهس كل ما أمامه ويمضي،
ولا يتوقف إلا في محطته الأخيرة،
والأكثر من ذلك أنه لا يستطيع العودة للخلف،،
(بيونغ يانغ تستعد للحرب)
أوامر عليا في كوريا الشمالية بالاستعداد للحرب
إثر أزمة الغرب مع روسيا
بسبب غزو الأخيرة لأوكرانيا...
جميع المسؤولين في بيونغ يانغ تلقوا أوامر
بالتحضير للتعبئة العامة والاستعداد للحرب
في أي وقت وتحت أي ظرف،
للوقوف بجانب أقوى حلفاء كوريا الشمالية
في العالم.. متهمين الغطرسة الأمريكية
في المنطقة بإشعال الأزمة الحالية...
حيث طالب الحزب الحاكم فى كوريا الشمالية،
جميع المسؤولين، بالاستعداد للتعبئة،
وحتى للحرب، عقب تدهور العلاقات
بين روسيا والدول الغربية على خلفية
عمليتها العسكرية فى أوكرانيا،
ونقلت إذاعة "آسيا الحرة" عن مسؤولين حكوميين
فى بيونج يانج، قولهم إن السلطات الكورية
الشمالية انتظرت أياما لتخبر المواطنين
بشأن العملية العسكرية فى أوكرانيا،
التى تهدف إلى نزع سلاح كييف ودرأ تهديداتها
انطلقت العملية العسكرية الروسية
فى الرابع والعشرين من فبراير،
لكن بيونج يانج لم تخبر أعضاء الحزب
إلا بعد يومين،
وقال أحد المسؤولين أنه فى السابع والعشرين
من شهر فبراير أخبرنا أعضاء كل لجنة
حزبية إقليمية.
وأوضح أن اللجان أخبرت الأعضاء بأن
"حليفنا القوي، روسيا، فى حالة حرب
"، مضيفا: "العلاقات الدولية متوترة مع روسيا
التى هي في حالة حرب، لذلك طالب الحزب
الحاكم بأن يكون الجميع جاهزاً للتعبئة
فى جميع الأوقات
وذكر مسؤول آخر للإذاعة:
"لم يصرحوا فقط بأن روسيا في حالة حرب،
بل أمرونا أيضا أن نكون مستعدين للدخول في حرب
على الفور تحت أي ظرف من الظروف".
(نعود للقصة)
في ذلك اليوم عقد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
والزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون
أول قمة بينهما لتعزيز "العلاقات التاريخية"
بين موسكو وبيونغ يانغ، على خلفية
مأزق ديبلوماسي مع واشنطن حول النووي،
صافح بوتين مطولا كيم على جزيرة روسكي
قبالة ميناء فلاديفوستوك (أقصى الشرق الروسي)،
حيث وصل الزعيم الكوري الشمالي في رحلة
بقطاره المصفح دامت حوالي 10ساعات.
وقال بوتين:
"أنا على ثقة بأن زيارتكم اليوم لروسيا
ستساعدنا في أن نفهم بشكل أفضل
كيف يمكننا معالجة الوضع على شبه الجزيرة الكورية
وما يمكن لروسيا أن تفعله لدعم الخطوات
الإيجابية التي تجري حاليا".
وأضاف:
"على الصعيد الثنائي أمامنا الكثير من العمل
لتنمية العلاقات الاقتصادية".
من جهته قال كيم "
أعتقد أنه سيكون لقاء مفيدا جدا لتنمية الروابط
التاريخية والصداقة بين البلدين،
لتصبح أكثر استقرارا،ومتانة".
وفي ختام القمة، قال كيم إنه أجرى محادثات
"مفيدة جدا" مع بوتين، مضيفا:
"لقد أجرينا للتو تبادلا مفيدا جدا لوجهات النظر
حول قضايا ذات اهتمام مشترك".
غادر كيم فلاديفوستوك غداة قمته الأولى مع بوتين،
الذي اشتكى من "النيات السيئة" للأميركيين في تعاطيهم
مع الأزمة النووية الكورية.
ووصفت وكالة الأنباء الكورية الشمالية الرسمية
اللقاء بين الرجلين بأنه كان "ودياً".
ورغم أن اللقاء لم يُترجم بإعلانات ملموسة،
إلا أنه سمح لبيونغ يانغ بإعادة إحياء التواصل
على أعلى مستوى مع حليفتها في الحرب الباردة،
وأتاح لموسكو العودة إلى واجهة المساعي
لحل الأزمة الكورية.
وتحرك القطار المصفّح الأخضر اللون
الذي يقلّ الوفد الكوري الشمالي،
من محطة القطارات في هذا المرفأ المطلّ
على المحيط الهادئ، متوجها إلى بيونغ يانغ
في رحلة تستغرق حوالي عشر ساعات.
وظلت هذه القصة حديث العالم لفترة ليست بالقصيرة
قال باحث في رسالة نشرت في المواقع الرسمية
لبيونغ يانغ
"السبب العميق للأزمة الأوكرانية أيضًا يكمن
في استبداد وتعسف الولايات المتحدة".
واتهم الباحث الولايات المتحدة بتبني
"معايير مزدوجة" حيال بقية العالم،
وبالتدخل في الشؤون الداخلية للدول الأخرى
باسم "السلام والاستقرار" مع "إدانتها بلا داع لإجراءات
الدفاع عن النفس التي تتخذها (هذه) الدول
لضمان أمنها القومي".
وكتب في الرسالة
"الأيام التي كانت فيها الولايات المتحدة تهيمن قد ولت".
وأردف الباحث
"الخلاصة هي أن كل هذا خطأ الولايات المتحدة".
إلى جانب الصين، تعد روسيا أحد حلفاء كوريا الشمالية
القلائل.
لذلك فقد عارضت موسكو
باستمرار الضغوط التي تمارس على بيونغ يانغ
بشأن برنامجيها النووي والبالستي
ودعت إلى تخفيف العقوبات الدولية المفروضة
عليها. واليوم جاء الوقت ليرد أصحاب
العيون الضيقة دينهم لموسكو،
فكيف ستكون ردة فعل أمريكا والدول الغربية؟